we have a 1.6 trillion dollar student
loan problem in America let me help you
with how that happens ok you cannot be
the father who looks at your son and
assists him in going $100,000 in debt in
your name and 20,000 in his own name who
gets an English degree hoping to have a
career of making $30,000 a year as a
father that makes you a failure you have
failed your son
because you've been stupid now think
about it okay if you take someone that
you supposedly loved and you lead them
into a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in debt in a career field where
they hope to make thirty thirty five
thousand dollars a year that makes you
stupid
inept and then have the unmitigated gall
to ask them to pay back the loan that
you signed for fail your father checkbox
part of our Student Loan debacle is a
parenting failure where parents don't
look at 18 year olds and go no darling
that's stupid because 18 year olds have
the capacity to do stupid things and as
loving parents it is our job to assist
them in not doing that not assist them
in doing that don't assist people to do
stupid things in doing things that you
know are going to bring them harm that's
just dumb well he's an adult
listen not only is he 18 he needs you to
speak into his life and say no darling
that is not wise if you want to get an
English degree and make $35,000 a year
work your butt off blowing leaves off of
rich people's lawns rich people or Fred
leaves get you a leaf blower and make
$20 an hour and go to Community College
and get an associate's degree in
journalism and then go write for a
magazine you do not need a four-year
degree at Yale in English to work for a
magazine
you don't okay I've got 40 people 45
people on our staff that are
professional content people that really
know their stuff they're world-class
storytellers they're world-class writers
and editors they produce content around
here by the bushel basket every day yes
I do know what I'm talking about I hire
these people they work with me I write
with them we create things together
they're brilliant they know what they're
doing and none of them win $120,000 in
debt to get that degree and then you
turn around and ask him pay for it by
September somebody I'll smack that dad
seriously and if you're that dad maybe
I'm smacking you right now because
you're about to be that dad don't sign a
Parent PLUS loan dummy Parent PLUS
stands for stupid that's what it stands
for Parent PLUS loan is stupid it's
parents financing stupidity there is no
need to go into debt to go to college
let's try that again there's no need to
go into debt to go to college the
average in-state tuition in America
today is twelve thousand dollars a year
you can make that delivering pizza four
nights a week there is no need to go
into debt to go to college
well I want to live in the dorm room
that's not going to college that's
living in the dorm room what are we
after here the college experience or the
knowledge choose where you're going to
school carefully and pay the least
possible amount for it if you don't have
the money or someone writing you big
checks this is how this works boys and
girls the reason we have a crisis is
people when it comes to the subject of
Education have no education we're making
stupid the paradox is we're making
stupid choices when it comes to
education we're getting degrees in
things that have absolutely no
application in the marketplace no
ability to give you a return on
investment you get a degree a PhD in
German polka history and then wonder why
you can't get a job
it's dumber than a rock and we just said
well everybody just needs an education
no everybody needs an education that's
applicable that has a marketplace value
otherwise you have paid for something
that it was an intellectual luxury and
you have to have the extra money to do
that
you don't go $220,000 in debt for an
intellectual luxury it's stupidity on
steroids stop it we have a parenting
crisis in America moms and dads you need
to love your children enough to not
participate in their crazy and guide
them away from crazy no darling you're
not going across the state line we don't
have the money you just tripled your
tuition just to go to a school that
looks exactly like this one with
different football team it's blue
instead of orange or red instead of
purple that's all it is it's the same
stinking place virtually I mean hi gosh
it's just crazy y'all it's crazy crazy
crazy crazy crazy stop it